I founded this institute to take the
risk out of love no more uncertainty no
more wondering if you've chosen the
right partner no more divorce we were
the first to build the machines to
conduct the test to make the bond of
love
stronger I really want to work
here a lot of famous people study there
really like who Ginger Spice she's my
favorite I
know how do you ever come up with an
idea like this what inspired it I think
that love is something so elusive who
cannot even analyze who cannot and I
don't know how why it's so difficult to
fall in love right now and especially
the younger generation and you see all
of them that they're using these crazy
dating apps and they're swapping right
or left with their finger and their nail
in order to find the perfect match and
in general love goes through screens and
not through eyes that's what we're also
showing with this test machine that it's
uh just one click and then you're
waiting on a on a screen and you are
waiting for the result and uh people are
letting their emotions and they are uh I
mean their own feelings to just a
machine to decide about them how people
are letting technology to decide about
everything in their life that's the mean
thing about technology it is taken over
the world and continues to be taking
over the world you know you can just
give AI your your idea and I'll write
the script for you exactly and that's
what we try to say with the movie that
you cannot let an AI decide about uh
about love Yeah and uh unfortunately
decide I mean if you will see how many
younger people are using these dating
apps and uh they're using them also in a
way that it doesn't make sense because
they're meeting somebody by just texting
and then they're meeting real person and
there is no chemistry and there is
nothing but they are already idealizing
something just from text just from a
screen and congratulations to Apple
because I didn't notice a single cell
phone in this film are other levels of
Technology other than the microwave type
thing that was there is that on purpose
you just wanted to limit all kinds of
forms of that we usually see in movies
these days yes we uh when we agreed with
Papa decided to remove all the
technology from the movie no no no no it
was uh because we're trying to make a
comment on technology uh we try to keep
everything in an analog way and uh to
create a go that it's going if so
everything H takes place probably at the
end of the previous Century or we don't
know exactly when it's
Timeless
um but we try to create that feeling to
give that feeling the Timeless feeling
in the film and to keep only one
technological device which is the test
machine and everybody goes there to find
answers about their own feelings and
their own emotions and at the same time
everything is I mean the last reference
of the movie is not in Hill that people
are watching in cinema because hug Grant
is the only one who knows go his love um
and I heard that you were trying to get
Hugh Grant to play the Luke Wilson role
is that
true yes and the day that he said no I
was in Toronto and I was walking outside
from a cinema and I saw on the Marquee
that something else was written and I
said okay hug Grant right now your name
will go up there I thought Luke Wilson
by the way was great he's he was perfect
for this Ro to be honest yes and uh
we're very glad that we have him and not
hug Grant because I prefer that hug
Grant is on the cinema uh so yes it was
we're very lucky to have speaking of
actors in this so beautifully cast with
Jesse Buckley my God and rized and
Jeremy Allen White who's very popular
right now on the bear I don't think that
was happening when you were making the
movie um he has already done the first
season he' done it had it run had people
and he was already quite uh famous um
but yes I mean um I'm very glad that we
have them because she always surprises
me she's great in whatever she's doing
and uh re is always a chameleon uh from
playing something dramatic to something
comedic but we have never seen both of
them in something romanic right so I was
really hoping for this romantic
chemistry that they will have on screen
and I hope that we achieve that and the
movie is about her character it's not
about uh for sure we are also focusing
on the two other characters but it's
about her own decisions and how you can
escape from a relationship that the
society tells you that it's perfect and
move on in your life and find something
that makes you feel more real even when
you are moving a nail and you are
feeling the pain but at the same time
you're feeling something real sometimes
you have to you have to sacrifice
something in order to find love and love
sometimes is painful but it's something
that we need so much in our life um this
is your first English language film do
you uh have any tredition about doing a
film in English or was that always your
desire to do um I think that even appos
in Greek language is a very Universal
story and I'm always trying to create
stories that are trying to talk about um
topics that exist forever in our life
like for example um uh the first one
that was about memory and grief this one
about love um and the next one I that I
want to make is about identity and to
play with them and about how the modern
society uh has changed the way that we
experience and to play in a little bit
uh also playful way sometimes a little
bit funny way but I think that in both
movies there are a lot of layers to
understand and to to recognize about
life and about how life is uh even if
it's very allegorical everything yeah
well apples which you're referring to
was your first film which opened the
Venice Film Festival a few years ago and
Kate Blanchett was on the head of the
jury I think and she saw that and she
reached out she was became a big fan of
that film yes uh I remember she is a
producer on this film now yes I remember
that I was in Venice and see I received
the message that Kate wants to have a
breakfast with me and I said at the
beginning I said no I will not go uh no
no no no of course I was like I was
like oh my God I was like okay I went
for breakfast with her and it's funny
because we stayed for two hours who
didn't eat anything and who were just
talking about movies and life and
uh we loved each other so much and we
immediately understand that we need to
work she asked me to to do something
together and uh we had already this
project so because we didn't have a role
for her she decided that she wants to
produce it she's just great she has she
has amazing Instinct in general amazing
Instinct I mean even if sometimes you
don't know exactly what she's trying to
describe when she's telling you
something the instinct is always perfect
so she knows very well what she's trying
to to tell you you and um I just love
her I mean she's she's wonderful and she
was very supportive in the whole process
of making the film I thought there was
tremendous chemistry it was very clear
this thing would fall like a sule if we
didn't believe between Jesse and RZ you
have to believe that and it's so
apparent there did they have time to
develop that
chemistry uh before they got on set or
um did they just come on and do What
actors sometimes do and just start um we
a few days of rehearsals with them uh
but also on Set uh in order to create
that chemistry uh first of all we became
very good friends all of us so it was
much easier in order to to build that uh
and at the same time um I was trying on
set to play
songs uh I had it I had selected a
different song for every
scene and uh the whole crew and cast
were hearing one song even in between
the takes that song was was always
connecting us even more and helping us
even more those the songs that are in
the movie no it's different songs uh
some of them are but most of them are
songs that I just love and I felt that
they were creating the right tone for
every scene the tone of this is so
perfect there is such a dry wit here
some of it's just dead pan funny when
you know like on these couples like
they're just interviewing them like the
girl who says we have sex every day
sometimes more than that for an hour and
and the guy they asked what do you like
about her most oh I like her hair you
know just delivered so perfectly you
know not over the top not trying to get
a laugh it's just there yes we try to
create something that looks very very
very humanistic and G but at the same
time funny and it has this dead pan
quality in a way uh but that was always
the intention to create this I I call it
as I said I mean it's the melancholic
smile tone but uh we have created for
this film that we had also in apples and
uh I think that it's something that I
want to continue exploring more this
kind of tone uh in films yeah you you're
going to you said you're going to do
another film dealing with identity we
follow a group of extras background
actors because also right now um they're
trying to make them AI all of them uh so
we will follow a group of B round extras
uh uh that they're playing in famous
movies from
1984 uh the first scene starts at
Terminator and it's about how we all try
to be protagonist in our life but we're
still extras in this
world um and about the roles the
different roles that we're playing and
how we can find our own identity wow
that's great I you know how do you come
up with all this stuff it's just amazing
you had two other writers on this by the
way you don't do this by yourself but I
I'm always finding the ideas uh but it's
always even the new one I mean the
extras idea it's it's about how people
are trying to be from the background in
the foreground uh like people right now
through social media and Tik Tok are
trying to be the from the background in
foreground so I'm always trying to
understand people around me and play
with what they are doing in their life
and to create something that is a little
bit different who inspired you to go
into this business um the movie that
made me to want to be a filmmaker was
the Trum Man Show it's a movie that I
really love it has an amazing prophecy
about our life and uh for me it has the
perfect balance the perfect balance
between comedy and drama the perfect
balance between how you can create
something that is high concept but at
the same time very grounded and how you
can create something that looks like
dystopian but at the same time it's so
humanistic and it's also a
character-driven story unfortunately a
lot of conceptual stories recently care
a lot about the concept and not about
the characters Christopher Tracy did the
score I was really a beautiful uh
underscore here he's a great great great
composer and a great talent it's funny
that he's uh uh he started making movies
uh three years ago uh he was doing other
stuff before and uh for me he's one of
the next big talents here in us and I
hope that a lot of people will start
working more with him beautiful all of
the cinematography the production design
was perfect you unique in it what what
were you thinking with the production
design in developing that office and
what it looks like um with Zazu Myers
that we got is also a super talented
person I think that uh we tried to
create something that looks really warm
very inviting for all the couples that
they're going there but also because we
try to create something Timeless that
looks a little bit 90s as we said but we
don't know exactly when so we try to
create this to give this Timeless
quality in everything in all these
conceptual stories are trying to make
something very futuristic but for me
it's much much stronger when you are
creating something that it's really
grounded and you are playing with
something that you have already seen
with the absence of technology and not
uh Apple cell
phones uh there are so many wonderful
movies about love that we've seen I mean
it's a big subject in movies over the
century of movies and I looked at this
movie and I said this is truly about
love it comes through it was very
important to to show love through
glances and to create something really
pure to create all this anticipation
about to to kiss somebody that it's
happening for me this kiss scene is much
sexier than all the sex scenes that we
could have done in this movie probably
so that's what we try to show something
really pure a and you succeeded 100%
well thank you for coming out and
showing it here at the Academy this is
uh Kristoff and uh thank you and good
luck with the film as we go along thank
you so much Pete thank you so much and
thank you all for being here today thank
you